you know successful negotiation is not
about getting to yes it's about
mastering know and understanding what
the path to an agreement is now people
are constantly trying to trap us by
getting us to say yes I mean we get
hammered on this every single day
lawyers actually have a term for it they
call it cornering and there's there's a
theory of negotiation out there called
mere agreement that says the more little
yeses I get out of you the more likely
you are to say yes to a big yes so I
don't know if that was ever true but I
know that we get hammered so much day in
and day out with people trying to trap
us with us trying to corners trying to
lead us places by getting us to say yes
that we get defensive
instantly when someone tries to get us
to say yes so you've got to get out of
the getting to yes mindset instead of
understand that yes is commitment and
we're always worried about what we've
let ourselves in for when we make a
commitment there are three kinds of
yeses there's commitment confirmation
and counterfeit people are most used to
giving the counterfeit yes because
they've been trapped by the confirmation
years so many times so the way you
master know is understanding what really
happens when somebody says no when yes
this commitment no is protection if you
say no and you just protected yourself
you're actually a little more open to
hearing what the other side has to say
because you're not worried about what
you've committed yourself to so you can
take most questions that are designed to
get yes and simply turn them into the
same question where the answer is no and
it gets you to the same place if a boss
gives an employee an impossible task and
the employee says we want me to be
successful don't you
well that's pushing for yes the flipside
question of that instead is do you want
me to fail it's stunning what people are
comfortable saying no to so first of all
understanding that you can use a note or
make somebody feel protected and a
little more open-minded to hearing what
you have to say now the second move
after that is what do you want them to
say next what you really want them to
say is that's right you want to be able
to summarize how they feel about things
and what the circumstances are so that
they feel that you got it so much so
that they look at you in the eye and say
that's right and that's what we say at
any given point in time when we see
something that we know is completely
true or that we're in complete agreement
we say that's right you know almost as
if we're so totally behind it may even
have been a partial epiphany or so
behind it we've just heard something
that we feel is the indisputable truth
and in many cases are really good that's
right is summarized in a way that the
other person was actually blind to they
didn't know that those forces were
driving them are those passions but when
you say it to them it it creates an
epiphany on some level we pointed
something out to them that's true that
they didn't even realize they're showing
us and telling us that they feel empathy
from us and anytime you feel empathy
from somebody else you feel bonded to
them you want to collaborate with them
you want to do whatever you can for them
and that's a great way to find out you
know what kind of latitude somebody has
in a deal and everybody's got latitude
someplace what you want to do is put
people in a position where they feel
connected enough to you that they're
willing to collaborate with you they're
they're willing to show you the things
that they were scared to tell you about
before you know the cards that everybody
holds in a negotiation that if you could
just see those cards you might be able
to negotiate a completely different deal
well that's where this entire approach
is really going because everybody has
cards they're not showing in a
negotiation everybody and if you can get
the other side to show you those cards
we call them black swans the little
things that make all the difference if
you can get them to show you the black
swans too
you of those black swans that you can
probably make a better deal than you
ever had in mind